[Music]  katie holmes joins the cast of oceans  eight you know I'm a fan of all the  oceans movies so I'm happy that it's you  know has so many amazing women in it so  many amazing actresses is really so much  fun to be a part of but it started with  oceans 11 so why they moving backwards  because the ladies need their own movie  also this all ladies yeah fantastic it's  gonna be so good-looking you tease about  your character I can't say anything  nothing at all no it's just it I'm it's  like and playing myself it's this a  cameo Katie will cameo alongside the  cast of the star-studded 2018 flick  which includes Anne Hathaway Sandra  Bullock cate blanchett rihanna and more  he or she is arriving on set in new york  city on wednesday and katie isn't the  only new addition to the cast ET also  confirmed Friday that James Corden will  make an unknown appearance  you